Okay.
Let's talk about something I've been getting
a lot of questions about over the last couple
of weeks and the gist of the questions has
been, Hey David, why are you listed on Jordan
Peterson's new website?
Think spot.
Why are you involved with Jordan Peterson?
Are you part of it?
Are you not part of it?
I've not heard you mention it, but they list
you.
So let's talk about it.
I haven't been saying anything publicly because
there's been a lot going on behind the scenes,
but I am ready to talk to you today about
it and I can report to you that I am no longer
in any way part of Jordan Peterson's website
think spot.
But I do believe I owe you a full explanation
about everything that's gone down.
And I'll tell you about it today.
So months and months ago, in fact, it was
on July 2nd Jordan Peterson emailed me and
said, Hey David, I'm starting this thing.
Think spot with some other people.
Uh, we're bringing in a bunch of high profile
contributors.
I thought of you, here's an introduction to
the people running it, talk to them.
And I had no further contact with Jordan Peterson.
I was put in touch with the folks at think
spot, all nice people.
The idea was, Hey, we're bringing in a bunch
of big name contributors to our website.
Thanks spot.
We want you to be on there.
You can do whatever you want.
Of course, whatever content you already do
or want to start doing or whatever you can
do.
So I of course have done a ton of criticisms
and take downs of Jordan Peterson and so when
I was approached I thought either a he and
they have no idea about that when they invited
me or they have an idea and they don't care
either way, it's not my problem.
So I thought, what is my philosophy on the
show about appearing on different platforms?
My philosophy on this show has been when I
am invited to a new platform, if it's not
a lot more work for our team because we are
stretched pretty thin, I do it and we've launched
on a ton of different platforms over the last
few years.
We launched on a platform called Steemit.
We launched our podcast on Pandora and Spotify
and radio.com we started put, putting our
clips on D tube and another one called library
LBR Y and three speak, and for lots of these
things there are people involved or founders
or corporations whose politics are not in
line with mine, but my view is my content
in more places without requiring a lot more
work for our team is good.
I can increase my reach, I can get my content
in front of people.
That's a good thing.
That was my thought with the thing spot partnership.
Now the launch of things spot got delayed
multiple times.
I think at first it was going to be early
August, then late August, then I don't even
know when it launched.
I think it was maybe in October, but eventually
it launched and when things bought launched,
it launched with really no other contributors
that I think were well aligned with the David
Pakman show.
Engagement was very low and I'll be honest,
my ability to engage with the platform is
also low because we're very busy at the end
of the day and then I saw this may actually
be an acutely bad platform for us to be on.
It's not like some of these others, uh, some
of these other platforms where there are tons
of contributors and I'm there putting up my
stuff.
It was like eight contributors that were being
promoted.
One of those contributors is Jordan Peterson's
daughter whose content was being sold for
even more than mine when I, which I found
sort of jarring and in Congress I think our
content is mostly around eating like a meat
only diet or something like that.
So long story short, I respectfully told them,
I don't think this is the right platform for
me.
The way it's shaken out, there's no real cadre
of other contributors that are kind of doing
what we're doing at the level we're doing
it in our space.
I don't think it's helping me.
They also said we're going to be transitioning
from a subscription model to more of a micro
payments model.
That makes it even less suited for us because
we're already on a bunch of those and I don't
want to spread our micropayment platforms
too thin.
So as far as I've been told you can no longer
subscribe to me on things spot.
They are in the process of removing my content
altogether and this is sort of more in line
with what's going to be our 2020 strategy,
which is now I think we are at a point where
I'm not looking to get on more and more and
more platforms and spread ourselves really
thin.
I'm reeling in the platforms that we're on.
We're going to focus on a few platforms that
are working well for us, so we're going to
try to grow YouTube.
We're going to try to grow Facebook and Instagram
video.
We're going to grow the podcast.
That will be the focus.
Now I've got a couple of questions on Twitter
saying, David, are you going to return the
money?
The first answer is we never got any money.
I mean we didn't get any money for signing
up and we were getting a cut of subscriptions
for people signed up.
I never got any money.
I don't know what the payment schedule is
supposed to be.
There was no money to return.
But beyond that, I don't know why I would
return money.
Like if people don't like this platform, me
keeping money gives them less money.
You think you would want me to do that?
But in any case, there is no money for people
got paid subscriptions and none of the money
ever came to me.
Uh, and I don't predict that it ever will.
So that's that.
And no, I also am not joining Dave Rubin's
new platform either.
I don't know much about that one, but I can
assure you I am not involved.
And that is the Thor
is
the story with think spot.